la mia credenza imbarazzante me la sono
creata da sola dopo aver visto un
episodio Esplorando il corpo umano sulla
gravidanza e la nascita mi ero convinta
che il bambino nascesse dallo spazio Fra
le tette
se le tette ce li hai
Allora allora
Infatti molti uomini a volte Diciamo un
pochino sovrappeso possono partorire
secondo Questa teoria Maurizio Costanzo
voleva un figlio da Maria De Filippi ma
lei non ce l'ha dato solo che a lui
nasceva dallo spazio tra il mento e
l'esterno
Ciao ragazzi Bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è da piccolo Credevo che
e per un tema così importante Ho pensato
di invitare all'interno degli Studios di
casa mia una ragazza che come me si è
persa in quella brutta parentesi che
diciamo divide eschere da Buongiorno
caffè Un like per Gesù sto parlando di
Silvia Dei trentenni già che mi ha
chiamato ragazza va benissimo benissimo
[Musica]
guarda quasi quasi preferisco un like
per Gesù iniziamo a sentire poi vediamo
che cosa esce e da lì te la mia
ispirazione
successo niente mi madre da piccola dopo
aver visto dove Story mi faceva credere
che i pupazzi la notte facevano i
festini e mi ritrovavo la mattina dopo
Spostati che era lei che si svegliava la
notte per spostarli io non avrei dormito
No questa è bella Beh mia madre Una
volta mi aveva detto tipo che esistono
davvero dei nani che tipo sai quando non
trovi una cosa poi ti giri e dici Ma
cavoli Avevo ragione e sono i piccoli
nani che vengono ti fanno gli scherzi
Okay da bambino credevo che i cani si
accoppiassero con i gatti quindi i cani
fossero degli uomini e invece i gatti
fossero delle donne e scoprire che in
realtà era tutt'altro E non è stato
facile questa male male Eh vabbè poi
nasceva o un gatto o un cane o Occhi di
gatto
così vi voglio vedere e possiamo
andarcene Scusate non posso farne a meno
di citare sempre cose che conosciamo
tutti Se state guardando questo video e
non Aggiungete Occhi di gatto potete
chiuderlo Anzi no scrivete
come puoi saper scrivere se non conosci
i fatti No purtroppo vinco
Tu hai gatti o cani sono allergica
Immaginati il mio cane l'ho preso tra
l'altro un antistaminico stamattina in
sicurezza perché suo padre le ha detto
questo ragazzo molto no poi vi spiego
ragazzi molto bravo eh Ma cosa fa mi
spiego cosa fa come vai lì ehm mi
vengono a prendere perché gli ho detto
come faccio ad arrivare fa No no non ti
preoccupare ti ti recupero io ah
Stai attenta Giampaolo Guarda io le
chiedo perdono perché sono andati a
prenderlo mio cugino e mio fratello
Cioè nel senso tu hai visto invece che
una limousine nera con un uomo
brizzolato e in livrea Hai visto Hai
visto due Scappati di casa che guidavano
un bidone dell'umido io gli ho detto Mi
raccomando ragazzi subito Quanti anni
hai
perché è sposata
e poi tra 10 anni sono 40 e quando è
entrato in macchina ha fatto auguri eh
oh oh per dire che poi ho menato
il messaggio del male ragazzi di stare
attenti mia madre Tra l'altro mi ha
detto Ma vai da sola Ah cioè forse la
Stefy ci raggiunge Mmm Speriamo Ecco
perché mi hai detto Ci raggiunge anche
la Guglielmo guarda ci raggiungerà anche
la Stefy ma dove dove sei Io molto fuori
dal centro
per oggi fai scherzando ti ho pure detto
Beh sai In realtà noi facciamo del
baiting e uccidiamo le persone come
Hostel Grazie per il defollo Chi è
Ragazzi cosa sta succedendo Chi è che
sta flirtando Ah il mio è mio vabbè
mettete in silenzioso il mio telefono
delle cose per cui ero più convinta da
ragazzina erano sicuramente quei fili
della corrente che avevano quelle palle
al centro e che io ero convinta che
fossero le Poké Ball dei Pokémon Spero
di non essere l'unica ma credo di no io
pensavo fossero voltorb in realtà che
sono i Pokémon Cioè li dovete catturare
Quindi è tutta colpa vostra il Pokémon
Go il gioco Allora allora tu hai già
detto Pokémon è colpa insieme e tu già
capisci che Uhm abbiamo incominciato
Allora ad allontanarci no sì hai ragione
Però Qui si sentono quei quattro anni di
distanza No perché quando sono usciti i
Pokémon il primo io avrò avuto 15 anni
eh io però io ne avevo 16 Eh ma un
sedicenne Cioè ma chi se ne frega a
tutta la vita ai Pokémon Forse sì hai
ragione solo che io ero già un po' panca
bestia un po' troppo fortunata Eh adesso
invece che cosa facciamo Andiamo fuori
dalle scuole dai licei nella speranza
fuori dalle università col cosino per il
per il metallo è presente
Ciao ospite Io ho un fratello siccome
sono una maggiore li raccontavo sempre
che era che era stata adottato anche se
non non era vero un giorno lui le
risposta mi disse che c'era uno squalo
che potevo uscire fuori dal water in
qualsiasi momento e non andavi più in
bagno dove metterò anche portarmi
all'ospedale perché avevo paura che dal
cesso potesse uscire un enorme squalo e
farmi non so cosa io non a questi
livelli che non vado più in bagno però
ancora un po' il terrore che qualcosa
esco e mi è successo una cosa a un certo
punto mi sono alzato ho finito ho
guardato c'era una cimice che equivale
più o meno lo squalo Beh sì Quindi tu
sei stata tutto il tempo con una cimice
sottovuoto che poteva ah ah anche solo
appoggiarsi sulla gamba quindi se vuoi
essere delicato sulla gamba sì sto
cercando comunque di mantenerlo friendly
perché sei venuto adesso perché parlava
di adozione voi mi avete fatto credere
Fino all'altro giorno che fossi stato
adottato pezzi
è vero
[Risate]
non c'è niente di te
simpatico e bello Infatti è buono e
generoso Io sono la matrigna cattiva Beh
a me hanno sempre detto Per esempio da
quando ero piccolo che io ero un
bastardo praticamente certo concepito
prima del matrimonio e Quindi
automaticamente un uno Snow e tu c'hai
creduto e quindi uno Slime
ricordo che quando ero piccola dissi a
mia madre che avrei voluto anche avere
la febbre in modo da non andare a scuola
il giorno dopo mia madre Allora mi disse
di non dire queste cose perché se fosse
passato un angelo mentre io dicevo
questa cosa mi avrebbe fatto vedere il
desiderio Quindi sarei stata male da lì
ho sempre avuto paura di dire
determinate cose ad esempio quando mi
arrabbio con una persona che dire tipo
ammazzati voglio che tu muoia Oh queste
cose qui Insomma Ciao
Genny Savastano Grazie mille cioè Grazie
a tua madre Perché sennò tu diresti
Spero che tu muoia eh
viva Che cos'è molto noti gli angeli
assassini No ragazzi
dovessero avverare tutti i desideri che
ho detto a voce alta dovrei avere la
metà dei miei nemici al cimitero e
soprattutto vivere in una villa nel
Colosseo Non so te poi sì Idem forse
sarei molto più alta molto più magra e
molto più alta è magra
Boh ma guarda che è una cosa bella del
web è che in realtà è tutto finto
Infatti io sono alta male
ci sta provando
ok Era una ciglia con mascara Beh tipico
commento di uno che ci sta per provare
tesoro era una figlia con mascara
Allora io ho due esperienze una È di una
mia amica quando partiva la ruota della
fortuna e tutti applaudivano e diciamo
Ecco a voi Iva Zanicchi lei pensava che
Iva Zanicchi fossero le persone del
pubblico che applaudivano fossero
chiamate così come un popolo Iva
Zanicchi l'altra cosa la pensavo io che
il bancomat fosse una banca che fosse
impazzita Eh appunto bancomat che
chiedesse soldi gratis
meravigliose Questo è bellissimo cioè i
bazzanichi sono stupendi il bancomat che
ti regala soldi che bello Dai che passa
l'angelo il bancomat che regala soldi
Buongiorno Io da bambina credevo che i
cammelli vivessero su Marte Ero
convintissima è un altro li ho visti
anche mia madre proprio convinta e lei
mi fa credere ma come
No non addosso Quindi le donne vengono
da Venere i cammelli vengono da Marte
Io da piccola credevo che sai i boschi
insieme di alberi piazzati lì belli
simmetrici ok Ho già paura è proprio
quella cosa lì io credevo che nascessero
perfetti così ho detto Silvia ma guarda
che li piantano così ho detto la piccola
ma in realtà era tipo tre quattro anni
fa
ma aspetta tu parli di quelli che
chiaramente sono stati piantati da
qualcuno
Ma gli alberi non sono nemmeno tanto
alti poi no no Erano sono rottissimi
da che prospettiva sono altissimi
non volevo prendere in giro tutte quante
le persone basse del mondo alla fine
sono solamente un numero sono tutti
quelli che pensano che i boschi No
ragazzi
Silvia Dei trentenni dovevate prendere
alla stazione questa qui è un
appuntamento secondo me non lo so del
terapista da chi dovevi andare tu oggi
Scusami Silvia Dei trentenni il trio di
ragazze le assomiglia Ma questo è
sequestro di persona ragazzi Mamma mia
No no no devo mandare per un messaggio
per sapere che cosa sta facendo questa
mia amica alla stazione da tre ore
quando ero piccina ero super
ossessionata da Sailor Moon e ho due
sorelle più grandi che ovviamente mi
prendevano sempre in giro e una cosa che
mi è rimasta impressa di quello che mi
diceva che Sailor Moon in realtà si
chiamava design e basta perché la sigla
diceva sei l'ormone
hai Iva Zanicchi prendono Secondo me la
medaglia per incapacità di comprendere
le canzoni che in realtà è Lord no
Esatto sei Lords Non ci sto a prendere
in giro una persona no per Sailor Moon
ragazzi soprattutto se sei sorella più
grande Cioè io non ci credo che sei sano
se prendi in giro per Sailor Moon quando
i tuoi cartoni erano David Gnomo volevi
dire uomo
devi da amico mio dai era uno gnomo col
cappello rosso enorme e andava in giro
perché i boschi
Allora lei non puoi permetterti di
prendere in giro tua sorella che guarda
Sailor Moon se sei cresciuta con David
Gnomo fondamentalmente sì
Io quando ero piccola prendevo tutti i
miei pupazzi e quando andavo a letto li
mettevo vicino a me sotto le coperte con
la faccia rivolta verso l'esterno
ovviamente perché sennò avevo paura che
soffocassero e lo facevo ogni sera e se
non dovevo farlo perché mi annoiava mi
sentivo in colpa e pensavo che morissero
di freddo e che potevano morire di
freddo e poi ce l'avessero con me di
conseguenza per tantissimo tempo ho
fatto questa cosa tutto Ora me le prendo
perché non avevo spazio nemmeno per
muovermi e va bene È già un bacione agli
amici ti prego no prendi la mia giacca
Oh ti prego no prendi la mia maglietta
No ma fa freddo ti prego no no prenditi
mia nonna in buona fede Però in modo
automatico Da piccola mi diceva che se
mangiavo due banane o più sarei morta in
più per convincermi Ah non prendere le
cose da terra mi diceva che se avessi
preso qualcosa a terra avrei preso il
tetano questa cosa a me avrei voluto il
ciclo a
bambini sempre mio non mi aveva detto
che se facevo la doccia con l'acqua
calda mi servono emorragia e sarei morta
veramente il modo migliore proprio per
allontanare un sacco di cose che ormai
fa più senso però non tipo non prenderlo
che se no L'uomo nero non prenderlo
perché Perché muori Queste sono le
vecchie nonne Questa è l'educazione
italiana Perché muori fine non è che
devi aggiungere
5-6 anni ero entrata attaccato
matrimoniale dei miei genitori e loro
volevano farmi andare via che
minacciarono dicendo che se non me ne
fossi andata che si sarebbero lavati la
Fede e io non capendo rimasti a mio
padre Misterio che se fosse arrivato
alla Fede e io sarei scomparso nel nulla
dalla memoria di tutti che sono Forse ho
letto avevo dormito prima di subito io
non avrei dormito mai più nella vita
interrompe raga' Hehehe e mi tolgo la
Fede tu scomparirai del dipende dalla
memoria di tutte
ma sai quante persone dovrebbero
scomparire
matrisante
cioè Vattene via perché se non muori è
sempre quello ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video se io ti
ringrazio ancora di cuore per per
esserti così prestata a questa cosa ti
ringrazio anche per aver rischiato
ancora la vita sì ringrazio te per
avermi fatto vivere questo Brivido di
essere recuperata da due Scappati di
casa Adesso mi fidata averci creduto
fino in fondo perché mi sono divertita
molto bene il ritorno infatti non è
andata ricordo sempre Come sempre vi
invito a farmi sapere qua sotto quali
sono state le vostre esperienze legate a
tema ma soprattutto quali sono altri
temi che mi piacerebbe vedere
all'interno di questa rubrica Se avete
dei suggerimenti visto che io zero
personalità e zero inventiva in questo
momento storico della mia vita vi invito
a iscrivervi al mio canale Al canale di
Silvia i trentenni che vi metto tutto
quanto in infobox e che semplice ciao
ciao Gu Grazie ciao a voi alla prossima
settimana vabbè